I love Hillsdale I've learned so much
there but it's my responsibility to go
out and use my education so this is a
wonderful bridge to go out and apply
what I've learned at Hillsdale
the Washington Hillsdale internship
program we call it whip for short we
raise students out to DC they take two
or three classes and they intern really
anywhere they want to the internship
program is this unique experience to see
being made for you what you've studied
on campus
I wanted to get a head start on figuring
out my career and really have any idea
of if this is the world for me having
this opportunity to both work but still
get my politics courses in was perfect
this is the center of the American
Republican government and that's what
I'm interested in and so this is where
all the opportunities are for me to find
out what I like about politics and kind
of where I want to be in the
conservative movement I'm an editorial
intern so every day I post our websites
videos I write posts about foreign
policy things that are going on in the
hill and I also get to occasionally
cover events and being in the room with
people like the vice president it's been
really exciting to kind of see news
happening right in front of you while
you may find yourself occasionally
making a cup of coffee you're also
probably going to committee hearings up
the hill or you're doing actual research
that that senior staff will then use to
bring in business so you really get to
kind of see the fruits you deliver in
your internship in DC
I don't think there's a better program
that a student could get but to spend
time on Capitol Hill every facet of our
life and as a resident and citizen of
the United States is based on what
happens in the city it'll give you a
really deep appreciation for what
Hillsdale
really is all about you will only find
it in a city like Washington watching
the mechanics of our government you take
classes and you're learning things and
talking about politics and history at
the same time that you're actually
experiencing it in your day to day
internship and that combination of
things makes for great learning anyone
no matter where they want to end up
after college can benefit from spending
a semester in Washington DC the
experiences you have here the classes
you take here the people you meet here
they will help you no matter where you
end up these people they really can
change your future and get you to where
you want to be I get a lot of resumes
across my desk when you look at a resume
you see pretty much the same thing over
and over it when we find somebody coming
out of college who has some practical
real-world experience it really sets
them apart those are the people we
interviewed the Kirby Center has
produced some of the best interns we
have found in all of the years that both
congressman McClintock and I have been
on Capitol Hill that's why we look to
them we know that the insurance they
send leave an indelible mark on this
office I have to look at the larger
picture about investing in your future
and that's what I feel like I'm doing
here and it's given me a lot of guidance
to what I'm gonna do after Hillsdale
that's very important it's coming up
sooner than you would think it just
really changed their life because they
now see what they learned on campus
those principals ideas put into practice
they see them alive in Washington DC
it's a transformative experience so
you've just got to take the leap of
faith and push yourself and push your
education to the next logical step come
to Washington DC